Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192 to David P you can
call any time of day. Here is our old friend
Juan calling in to say, David, you're wrong.
California is a disaster. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: David. Sir, you're talking a
lot of B.S. when it comes to Gavin Newsom.
Really? And the reason I say that is because
let's see California, right? How has
he solved? The tents on the roads.
Speaker 1: Did Gavin Newsom claim he solved
homelessness? I didn't hear him claim that
in his interview with Sean HANNITY.
Speaker 6: The turns on the sidewalks,
the stench in the public areas where the
homeless are. He hasn't done anything with
that, or at least many complaints that exist
about that. When he actually solved it 100%.
Then you could say, okay, all right, so he
did solve it, but you haven't solved it.
Speaker 1: So a first of all, is the new standard
that no state can be considered successful if
there's any homelessness, Well, then there are no
successful states in the United States. There is
homelessness in every state that I'm aware of.
I know Wyoming only has like 500,000 people. I
think there are still homeless people, even in
Wyoming. Okay. So if that's the standard, then
then we can't judge any state because every state
has some homelessness. I am not like a California
acolyte or like a fan, you know? As I've said
before, I've been to a number of U.S. states.
They almost all have good things and things
that are not so good. It can't be denied
that California's economy is one of the most
dynamic in the world. If California were a
country. It would be one of the most powerful
economies by itself in the world. The amount of
innovation, the number of Nobel laureates, the
amount of groundbreaking research in tech and
medicine that is coming out of California, it's
not coming out of I'm not going to, you know,
put any particular state on blast, but it's not
coming out of a lot of other states. California
operating with a budget surplus. It is
expensive in California. That's because
of that free market that right wingers love.
California's state income tax is progressive
and it goes all the way up to 13%. If you
pay 37% federally and 13% in California,
that's 50%. And then you add property taxes and
properties are expensive in California. I'm not
denying it's expensive. Part of the reason it's
expensive is because there's not enough housing.
Part of the reason it's expensive is because a
lot of people want to live there. Homelessness,
it's a major problem. Part of the reason
that homelessness is a problem in California
is the weather is good and it's a safe place. If
you have no home, that if you're stuck outside,
you're not going to freeze to death in, I don't
think, just about any part of California. You
could go up in the hills to ski resorts. I don't
think that's where the homeless people are. So
there are criticisms of California, but this idea
that there is a California exodus because of woke
high tax California and it's failing and all these
different things, it is simply not the case. I've
never lived in California. I don't intend to I
have no personal horse in this race. But that
is the reality. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. Sign up at join Patch Mint.com. I
want to see you there. And we will be
back with a new program tomorrow as well.